LIZ CHENEY OUSTER.
IF IT IS ALL RELATES TO THAT
DEMOCRACY BEAT.
POLITICIANS CAN'T REWRITE
HISTORY ON THEIR OWN, THEY NEED
MEDIA ENABLERS AN THAT IS WHAT
THE GOP HAS RIGHT NOW THANKS TO
RIGHT WING OUTLETS THAT LOOK THE
OTHER WAY AND IGNORE THE FALLOUT
FROM JANUARY 6 AND IGNORED THE
NEWLY OBTAINED VIDEO THAT CNN
AIRED FROM BODY CAM AND WILL NOT
HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
CRIMES OCCURRED AT CAPITOL.
IT IS OBVIOUSLY DESTABILIZING TO
DEMOCRACY AND CHENEY SAID SO,
CHALLENGING FOX ON FOX TO TELL
THE TRUTH LOUD AND CLEAR.
>> WE ALL HAVE AN OBLIGATION AND
I WOULD SAY FOX NEWS ESPECIALLY,
ESPECIALLY FOX NEWS HAS A
PARTICULAR OBLIGATION TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE KNOW THE
ELECTION WASN'T STOLEN.
>> YOU'VE SAID THAT NUMEROUS
TIMES.
>> BUT I'M GOING TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION.
>> IF YOU'RE SAYING FOX NEWS --
>> HE WASN'T HAPPY ABOUT THAT.
THE BANNER SAID FOX -- CHENEY IS
TAUNTING TRUMP.
THAT IS WHAT FOX WAS SAYING.
WHICH IS ALSO CHALLENGING FOX
AND NEW POLL NUMBERS SHOW WHY.
LET'S DIG INTO IT WITH PETER
WEHNER, AUTHOR OF THE BOOK "THE
DEATH OF POLITICS, HOW TO HEAL
OR FRAYED REPUBLIC AFTER TRUMP
"AND HE'S SERVED IN BOTH BUSH
ADMINISTRATIONS.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
LET ME SHOW YOU THE NEW PRRI
DATA THAT SHOWED 66% OF THE
REPUBLICANS SAY THEY SUPPORT AT
LEAST IN PART THE ELECTION
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, THE BIG
LIE.
THEN IF YOU LOOK AT REPUBLICANS
WHO TRUST FOX NEWS, THE NUMBER
IS HIGHER, 86% OF THE FOX NEWS
REPUBLICANS AND IF YOU LOOK AT
FOLKS WHO LOVE NEWS MAX AND OAN,
THE PERCENTAGE IS EVEN HIGHER.
96% OF THOSE VIEWERS, THOSE
REPUBLICAN VOTERS, BELIEVE IN
THE BIG LIE.
TO ME, PETER, THIS IS PRETTY
CLEAR EVIDENCE THAT LIZ CHENEY
IS RIGHT.
THAT THE FOXES OF THE WORLD NEED
TO TELL THE TRUTH MORE LOUDLY,
MORE AT ALL.
>> I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU.
LIZ IS RIGHT.
I'M GLAD SHE WENT ON FOX AND
MADE THAT INDICTMENT.
FOX HAS SOME SERIOUS
JOURNALISTS, SO DOES CHRIS
WALLACE, BUT BY ENLARGE THE FOX
PRIME TIME LINEUP IN MOST OF THE
STARS IN PARTICULAR, TUCKER
CARLSON ARE SPREADING MALICIOUS
LIES ABOUT THE ELECTION AND
THESE ARE NOT JUST QUOTE/UNQUOTE
ANY LIES.
THESE GO TO THE HEART OF
DEMOCRACY BECAUSE THEIR
UNDERMINING FAITH IN THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR REPUBLIC WHICH
IS TRUST IN THE ELECTION AND
REMEMBER, BRIAN, THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ITSELF DECLARED
THAT THIS WAS THE MOST SECURE
ELECTION IN HISTORY.
THESE ARE THE SPECIALISTS WHO
FOLLOW THESE THINGS.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT THE
ELECTION WAS STOLEN OR RIGGED.
AND YET, BECAUSE THESE NEWS
OUTLETS AND POLITICIANS IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND OTHERS
THREW THEIR HAT OVER THE TRUMP
WALL, THE MORE DELUSIONAL HE
BECAME AND THE MORE DELUSIONAL
THEY BECAME AND IT IS A REAL
THREAT TO OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> YOUR OP-ED FOR "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" THIS WEEK, IT IS CALLED A
GUEST ESSAY NOW AT "THE NEW YORK
TIMES," THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
REALLY STUCK WITH ME.
YOU SAID THE TRUMP BASE IS
ADDICTED TO THE BIG LIE.
AND YOU SAID ADDICTIONS ARE HARD
TO BREAK.
THAT IS -- IT IS KIND OF
UNCOMFORTABLE TO THINK ABOUT
TENS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE BEING
ADDICTED TO SOMETHING.
WHY DO YOU SAY IT AND HOW DO YOU
BACK IT UP?
>> THE REASON I SAID IT IS
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS TRUE.
AND LET ME EXPLAIN WHAT I MEANT
BY IT.
THERE ARE PHYSIOLOGICAL
ADDITIONS, CIGARETTES, DRUGS,
ALCOHOL AND THAT MEANS THAT THE
BODY CRAVES THEM BUT THERE ARE
PSYCHOLOGICAL AND EMOTIONAL
ADDICTIONS AND I THINK WHAT HAS
HAPPENED HERE, I THINK THE
POLLING AND THE EVIDENCE AND
CERTAINLY MY OWN CONVERSATIONS
WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS UNDERSCORE THIS,
WHICH IS THAT THEY DECIDE DID,
THERE WAS A PSYCHOLOGICAL NEED
OR LONGING OR CRAVING TO BELIEVE
THAT DONALD TRUMP WON, IT WAS
TOO DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO ACCEPT
THAT A PERSON THAT THEY HAD SUCH
A HIGH REGARD FOR AND PEOPLE AND
A MOVEMENT AND A PARTY THAT THEY
CONSIDERED DANGEROUS AND
MALICIOUS, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
AND PROGRESSIVISM, ONE, THEY
SIMPLY DIDN'T WANT TO ACCEPT
THAT BECAUSE THAT CREATED ALL
SORTS OF UNCOMFORTABLE FEELINGS,
AND IT WAS JUST MUCH BETTER AND
EASIER, NOT BETTER BUT EASIER SO
SAY THE ELECTION WAS STOLEN AND
THIS PLAYS IN BY THE WAY,
SOMETHING ON THE AMERICAN RIGHT
CONSERVATISM STOOD AGAINST WHICH
IS THE VICTIMIZATION MENTALITY,
THAT IS SO RAM PANT ON THE MESH
RIGHT RIGHT NOW.
AND NOW THEY HAVE THE NEWS
SOURCES FEEDING THAT ADDICTION,
GIVING THEM THE INFORMATION THEY
WANTED, PLAYING INTO
CONFIRMATION BIAS AND MOTIVATED
REASONING AND THAT EXPLAINS IN
PART HOW WE ARE WHERE WE ARE.
>> THIS RADICALIZATION IS THE
STORY THAT EFFECTS EVERY OTHER
STORY THAT WE COVER.
YOU SAID JUST NOW, TRUMP IS
TREATING HIS VOTERS LIKE VICTIMS
AND I THINK WE BOTH FEAR IS WHAT
THAT SETS UP DOWN THE ROAD.
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
MY REAL FEAR IS THAT IF THIS
CONTINUES THERE IS A
NORMALIZATION OF POLITICAL
VIOLENCE, BECAUSE THESE ARE
LINKS IN A CHAIN.
WHEN DONALD TRUMP IS SENDING OUT
AS HE DID YESTERDAY A STATEMENT
SAYING THAT THE ELECTION WAS THE
CRIME OF THE CENTURY, WHAT THAT
IS SIGNALING TO IS PEOPLE, WE
KNOW THIS FROM THE PROTESTERS IN
JANUARY 6th, WHICH IS SAYING
THIS IS THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL
ATTACK POSSIBLE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC SOCIETY AND YOU'RE
VICTIMS OF IT.
AND IN YOUR OWN MIND WHAT THAT
MEANS IS WE HAVE THE GREEN LIGHT
TO USE ANY MEANS POSSIBLE UP TO
INCLUDING VIOLENCE IF NECESSARY
AND FORCE TO UNDO THIS GRAVE
INJUSTICE AND UNLESS REPUBLICANS
STAND UP AND RESIST THAT, WE'R